AJA HAMMERLY: Hello.
Today, I'm going to show you
how to delete and restore
a project in Google
Cloud Platform.
To delete a project, start
at the Cloud Console.
Click Manage All Projects.
Then check the box next to the
project you want to delete,
and click Delete Project.
Enter the project ID,
and click Shut Down.
The project will enter
the deletion queue
and will be deleted
after seven days.
Why wait seven days?
Because it gives you the
chance to undo the deletion
and restore the project,
if you made a mistake.
To restore the project, start
at the Manage Projects page,
and scroll down to the bottom,
and click Project Shutdown
Impending Deletion.
Check the box next to the
project you wish to restore,
and click Restore.
Your project will
now be restored.
I hope you found this
Cloud Minute helpful.